a big dream for gen z is to sell flat
tummy tea young americans say can you
blame us for wanting to get insta-famous
a new survey of americans between the
ages 16 and 25 reveals that a third of
them aspire to be social media
influencers when asked what a third was
none of them could do fractions
and haven't they heard the good news
about free college but it gets worse
about a quarter of them admit being an
influencer is their actual plan once
they finish school
apparently gen z boys are actually more
likely than girls to believe that being
an influencer is their only career
option
but it's not just for young people
anymore
hello this is dr anthony fauci i got a
lot of time on my hands now so i'm an
influencer i know you like my influence
when i was ruining your livelihood and
so forth and now a shout out to my posse
the booster crew
[Music]
they're nice young people but they're
they're unmasked it's unfortunate so if
you could stay six feet apart i'd
appreciate it so now a word from our
sponsor it's a wuhan begone bat
repellent it's it's the only bat
repellent that's wet market approved
i should have won mad
jonathan if you could do it all over
again would you just become an
influencer oh god
i'm not sure what that means honestly
listen to to influence for the good is
always a good thing but you have to do
something that is worthwhile to follow
right and that's the problem
a lot of these influencers are doing
things that
really are not worthwhile following and
i think we need a generation of people
willing to stand up and saying i'm going
to lead i'm going to do something that's
worthwhile something that's good
something that's beautiful something
that is honest something that is true
and that's what's actually going to
influence people to follow and actually
to make sacrifices
sacrifices to attain something that's
worthwhile yeah i don't think gen z is
that deep
okay i can try something else
i i agree with you cat
i you are a bit of an influencer
and jen's if you're influencing people
with your comedy and you're here on the
show but
the idea that your job is going to be
just influencing then that's how that's
our career option no like one time i ate
ate soup on youtube live and
i was like why am i doing this
uh and i still don't know but i don't
know why people watched it either but
they did you weird you weirdos
um
yeah i think but you have to have a
purpose for wanting to like what do you
want to influence you know like you have
to be like this is something that's
important to me
and i want to have a platform for this
reason if you just want to have a
platform just so you can you know just
like be in a bikini and dance around
that's really not something to aspire to
especially because one of the best
feelings in the world is like to be on
vacation and be able to look ugly
they can't do not worry about a camera
exactly this is true lawrence do you
think that maybe they're getting the
sense that college isn't worth it
yeah and i support them on that um i
also don't really think that they really
want to be influenced
like the part of being an influence is
having an influence to stand your ground
and but the first moment someone
criticized them or said something about
it it breaks them they get broken so
quickly i think they just want to sell
stuff
on social media and then make a little
money on famous i mean just be famous
and be known for it which is there is a
business model for that start a product
and go out there and make the money on
your own
it's just sad because i i don't think
the young people actually realize their
value that's the problem right there
they don't realize they can be something
more and this is the easy
way out it's kind of sad for them jamie
is there social media in alaska yeah we
uh
we ever be everybody's bigger than
myspace
i'm getting i'm getting tired of social
media like i'm just kidding this this
makes me sad it really does i just had
to unfollow a woman this afternoon
because she turned around and then saw
me
[Laughter]
i do get i get approached sometimes um
you know rogaine asked me to do
something
uh
yamaka company um
they asked me to be on the cover of a
loan magazine
alone magazine
is am i the only one that when i heard
generate gen z i didn't like know what
it meant
am i the only one because i had to like
why don't they make it like can't they
come up with like an easier word so we
know how like couldn't they just say
idiots
um
listen i just want to say i'm sorry
don't send me angry messages on tick
tock i don't know how to get to them
[Laughter]
me neither hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else